according to interviews published in
Andy Green's book The Office the untold
story of the greatest sitcom of the
2000s Corel had told NBC brass that he
planned on signing a new office contract
that would be good quote for another
couple of years according to Barry
however Network executive simply didn't
reach out to him about negotiating a new
deal he planned on staying on the show
he told his manager and his manager
contacted NBC and said he's willing to
sign another contract for a couple years
so all of that was willing and ready and
on their side honest and the deadline
came for when NBC Executives were
supposed to give him an offer and it
passed and they didn't make him an offer
she continued noting that Corel didn't
want to leave the office behind he
simply had no other choice Corel was
like look I told them what I want to do
I don't want to leave I don't understand
it just is mind-boggling how that
happened and I feel bad because I think
a lot of people think he did leave the
show on his own Merit and it's
absolutely not true I'm telling you he
really wanted to stay and it devastated
all of us because he was the heart of
our show